foreign
crisis is out of control I mean 1.75
trillion dollars in student loan debt
it's just crazy that at this point it is
still such an issue the government can
just tell us we all can't go to work
right like I didn't know that that was a
thing I mean you look at social media
you look at Tick-Tock I mean all these
places that now anyone can have a
platform and a voice and I think that's
what's unique about Ramsey is that we're
the ones usually tapping the brakes
being like let's just wait and see how
this plays out I have said if you follow
the trends you fall for the traps and
that's what we're seeing with these
younger Generations because they're
super targeted marketing that's going
hey dude all you need is ten dollars
you're gonna get ten thousand next week
promise or how about Jason Bourne
telling you a fortune favors the brave
the smartest thing I've ever done with
money was by an engagement ring for
Stacy I would say the smartest thing
that I've done with money is invest
early on in line the smartest thing I've
ever done with money is pay off my house
early I just thought you have to live
with a mortgage payment forever and it
goes with you to the Grave when I found
out you can just pay it off early and
then live a life without a mortgage
payment it changed everything highly
recommend it the smartest thing I've
ever done with money is increase my
generosity to the outrageous level smart
thing I did with money was I paid into
my health insurance so both of my kids
could be born at the local hospital the
smart
with money was win over a half a million
dollars in scholarships to pay for my
education
so Dave over 30 years of doing radio a
lot of life has happened the world has
changed America has gone through some
things I mean you think about 9 11 Great
Recession covid student loan crisis and
you're there every day taking these
calls with people in the middle of some
really intense Economic Times what was
that like the first time that the nation
shut down
well that when I was on here
was
um the first story started rolling out
while we were live on the air on the
Columbine shooting
[Music]
and um
it was a
shut everything down
all news everything went to that all
Network stopped and went to breaking
news
whatever the other programming was on
radio TV everything stopped and went to
it
um it was it was iconic at the time and
um
and you know we're getting live
updates while we're on the air and you
know we've got to sit there and make a
decision are we going to
just keep talking about our stuff and
not address it but it it had put full
stop on everything so we just stopped
and started taking calls from people and
how they were feeling about it and what
else was going on and
um you know just giving people a place
to be angry and sad and all the emotions
that we all had that day
um
9 11 happened at 8 30 in the morning
and so we had a a little time because we
go on in the air in the afternoon to
figure out how big a deal that was and
we knew that it was shut down and we
actually pulled the plug on the show and
ran one of the network uh news feeds
over our Network I think we went back on
the air probably on Thursday or Friday
and again we just gave people a place to
Express themselves
and the anger
uh the Revenge the uh all you know the
fear all of it and then the stock market
you know they had of course it's
Wall Street literally is in the shadow
of the towers and so we shut down Wall
Street uh because they had
dust and Rubble in front of the building
so they reopened the following Monday
and we knew the stock market was going
to dive
it dropped 500 points in 14 minutes it
was crazy and so he knew that was good
so we're Preparing People you know on
Friday Thursday and Friday going Market
looks like they're going to reopen stock
market Monday just be ready let me tell
you what it's going to do it's going to
go down it's you know and everybody's
like oh see they've they've crashed our
economy with the towers and no they
haven't no they haven't it's your stock
market is just it's a drama queen so you
just gotta ride with it and and
um all the everybody's reporting
headlines major newspaper headlines big
print stock market takes dive after
Terror type you know and it was the
leading story for the you know 48 hours
after that
um
I couldn't find a single news outlet
that reported when it completely
returned 57 days later
back to where it was not a single one
but we did
we talked about that a lot because we
told people hang on it's like we always
do hang on you're playing the long ball
you're playing long ball and it came
back so those those were dramatic
lengthy
things uh that have happened and then
you know you have other
big news events since then that
I gotta sit back and go is this big
enough to even address it
we even used to have a stock market
report at the close of the day because
stock market closes by the time we get
off the air and we would take a live
thing at the one of the last few
segments of the show and Report
Woodstock you know Dow closed up Dow
closed down and we figured out people
were not listening to us for that they
don't care
and I I was probably the only one that
cared and when I quit reporting it I
quit checking it too so I don't even
care
yeah it's definitely a show about Hope
and the Common Thread there is you know
it's kind of a Voice of Truth in a world
gone mad we're there to be like the
sky's not falling stay calm it's gonna
be okay and those principles you know
ride throughout different topics now
from Ken with career and Christina with
the student loan crisis and you know
deloney with covid and Ken with a great
resignation we're seeing you know money
touches all of these different areas in
a big way and we're expanding the show
as well to cover more topics have you
guys seen any uh Trends or threads in
the calls you've been taking the last
few years the student loan crisis is out
of control I mean 1.75 trillion dollars
in student loan debt and we're seeing
people just completely weighed down with
this debt I mean they tell students
going to college this is good debt
you'll be able to pay it off easy and
it's like what we're saying is it's not
that easy we're seeing people who do
have a lot of regret with it so
um that's just crazy that at this point
it is still such an issue but thankfully
you know we get to help people walk
through it and kind of change their
mindset that this isn't something that
you have to carry with you for the rest
of your lives like this is something
that you can attack and attack it fast
and get it gone for good yeah a thread
that touches all of this is we tell
people that you can happen to your life
it doesn't just have to happen to you
you can take control you can have agency
and that touches every single piece of
this from mental health to Career to
relationships to money it's amazing how
that is really the foundation is we're
going to help people gain control and
they're going to do it they're the hero
we're just the guides yeah I think when
we look back many years from now on the
pandemic era I think we could say that
it was the great reflection I think
because of obviously in the early days
and depending on what you believe about
it where you live certainly people had
to confront their mortality you know and
then I think the other thing that
developed over time is people had to
confront how little they control you
know it was like I can't like if the
whole world shut down over this and the
way I do with my life the way I do my
work changed radically and it did
and then I think people had to confront
I don't control very many things and I
think they began to look for places in
their life where they could control
things and certainly in the space of
work you talk about what's changed so
much uh I think people realize you know
what I want to work in a place where I
feel valued I think that was a big
knee-jerk reaction I I don't want to be
a commodity I want I want to know that
that my company that my leader values me
I think I want to do something that I
enjoy I spend the majority of my life at
work and I just realized wait a second
there's a different way to do work and
so you talk about things like remote
work certainly existed prior to the
pandemic but phrases like hybrid work or
companies are still trying to figure out
all this and then you got workers trying
to figure out how do I want to do my
work where do I want to do my work how
does it fit and so I think that's a big
reaction to
uh the fact that people are now going I
can control some things you know we
early on in the pandemic we did a a
wonderful thing called the a night of
Hope and we just talked about it's
something that Davis said for decades
control the controllables and so I think
we've seen a big shift certainly in the
workspace and how am I going to spend
that majority of my time and it's all
about what can I control and I'm going
to try to do that and I think that's
something that has definitely shifted as
a result of the pandemic yeah I agree
with that I think after 9 11 when the
comments I heard most regularly by
people who were two three decades older
than me was they kept saying this
doesn't happen here it was a
psychological shift that oh this could
happen right and I think very I think
you nailed it kin I think through the
pandemic people had to confront
oh the government can just tell us we
all can't go to work right like I didn't
know that that was a thing
um oh this many people can just get sick
like this many
I don't think any of us were going about
our days thinking this was a possibility
and like you mentioned I think as you
really realize oh I control very very
little and it's disconcerting
psychologically right and then you have
to build back okay well can I control
then suddenly you start to realize wait
a minute I can control a whole lot more
than I thought I could right so it's
this dip and uh so I think that's that's
the common thread I can't do this I
can't do this yeah tell your
mother-in-law you're not coming for
Thanksgiving it's you can and it's like
oh you know what I mean so we're giving
people hope but you gotta you gotta ride
ride through it with them right yeah and
on the money side we've seen I mean Dave
you've seen a lot of money Trends come
and go we talk about this in the
Building Wealth event all the get rich
quick schemes we're now seeing pop back
up and they're in new ways now Rachel
with you know cryptocurrency and nfts
and nothing down real estate just made a
comeback it seems like everything has
changed but also nothing has changed the
mentality is still there when the voice
is speaking into it now
are greater I mean you look at social
media you look at Tick Tock you look at
YouTube I mean all these places that now
anyone
can have a platform and a voice and and
I think that's what's unique about this
about Ramsey is that there's been 30
years of groundwork of something proven
so when something kind of flashy pops up
that looks like a good idea
and that everyone jumps on it we're the
ones usually tapping the brakes being
like let's just wait and see how this
plays out crypto let's waste this plays
out nfts I literally read an article
today and it was talking about all the
celebrities that have come out endorsed
and it was like
you know so and so came out indoors and
then the nfts went and they lost 99 of
their value you know you're seeing all
this happen and we're the ones steady
through the trends and the flashiness to
say hey let's just let's just hang there
was an Andy Griffith
clip I saw and I was like this is like
literally for our time and I'm gonna
butcher it but basically he's saying
yeah this man is saying to him you know
we'll let the kid decide let the kid
decide and Andy's like no no no kids
will always go with the flashy thing
they'll always pick up the flash you
think because they're thinking only for
the moment but I know what that flash
you think can do long term and I was
like it's just so good because these
flashy things you know just pop up and
we're the I feel like hopefully the
voice of reason and the culture are
saying oh it sounds good in the moment
just hold off yeah hold on think long
term I have said if you follow the
trends you fall for the traps and that's
what we're seeing with these younger
Generations because they're super
targeted marketing that's going hey dude
all you need is ten dollars you're gonna
get ten thousand next week I promise or
how about Jason Bourne telling you the
fortune favors the brave
sign up I mean when Jason Bourne says
that you trust Jason Bourne right yeah I
mean how do you think of the day hunting
when it was just radio there wasn't I
mean we do know that Jason Bourne is not
a person he's a character
we do
hey can I this is this is the the mental
health guy asking you like I I I really
want to know this
um how's your mental health
I have a firm grasp I'll stop anytime I
want I have a firm grasp on Dave's
mental health it's not great
um why is it so hard
the path is clear it's not it's like how
do you lose weight and exercise it's not
it's not challenging yet it is a
perplexing trillion dollar industry
little less than you make
um there's not a scheme in seven to ten
years you can have everything you have
in your life paid off and you'll be on
the road to being a millionaire which
means you can give wildly and your kids
are going to be okay
why is that message so I guess unsexy
and why is it so hard to follow because
it just doesn't sound challenging
I think we're wired to search out the
fastest easiest way
we want the um the most efficient
fastest easiest way the problem is is
that when you
believe a lie
on what is the fastest easiest way
that that's where the issue comes in and
so you're just but the Bible says that
no discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields the Harvest of
righteousness
no one likes
every one of us have a kid inside of us
that wants what we want right now I want
it I want it now I deserve it I want the
cereal mommy I'm going to throw a fit on
the cereal aisle right we all are have
that cereal out kid inside of us and
but adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good adults
understand there's a price to be paid
that one definition of emotional
maturity is the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater good
and I'm
and if you dare tell someone that is
immature emotionally whether they're 52
or 12 that they need to delay pleasure
they will come back at you with every
bit of their intellect
every bit of their anger
um every bit of whatever call you names
everything else because you have dared
to
call out the the the mythology that
they're the the path they're on is that
they're dialing into uh
it's not gonna work for you and so you
know anytime we challenge
uh that then they come back at you and
go oh well you're just the people say a
cup of coffee a day and you'll be rich
and we're like uh yeah it's an example
it's a math example calm your butt down
but um but you know the it's but the
point is when you spend ten dollars or
fifteen dollars a day on coffee
and then you have your student loan
still 14 years later and you're still
paying it then something's off I mean
you're you've not addressed what's going
on and so but
again you're that that's where the
criticism comes back is you dare call
people out on their stuff
uh because you love them and you want
them to do better but you get a very
childish reaction and we all have the
ability to do that me too yeah don't
tell me I can't do something you know
and so we all have that ability to rise
up against that but
um I I think it's just immaturity yeah
more than anything and
when you the truth thing is when you
tell people the truth about how to get a
job
or the truth about how here's how you do
this relationship or hear the truth
about what you've got to do with your
money they hear it even if they don't
like it if it touches truth as a way of
getting to you and so you know and they
know you love them
and we love them we care about them
so the impact of this stuff Dave over 30
years we're now seeing the fruits of
that generationally I mean you meet you
know what we call Financial Peace babies
the kids of parents who went through
financial peace who have done this plan
now they're growing up in this culture
did you find that starting to Trend over
the last few years yeah we had to be
real careful to name them Financial
Peace babies because some guy got on
there and he goes I'm a Dave Ramsey baby
and I'm good no you ain't
yeah we're gonna call you a financial
peace baby oh yeah okay I get it